Hello Freak bitches.
And I'm not trying to,
I'm just trying to like,
like in high school I was like,
you know,
the,
the wise ass kid who had awful grades,
I was on Ritalin,
I was a mess.
And so Ritalin in high school
who I was on Ritalin since like,
uh,
like right at a preschool shit,
you look at the early uh,
government documentation on,
on Rhydlin.
This is not a joke.
Oh,
there's these big books.
My mom had them,
there's photos of me.
They tried Ritalin out.
I was part of the test group home.
We would get little orange tablets and
then we get little yellow tablets and we
have triangular orange tablets for awhile.
And My,
I went to a place called the national
research center and I was a hyperactive
kid and they said,
ah,
here we're trying this stuff out.
My mom had me on Ritalin from like a
preschool all the way to 12th grade.
Holy Shit.
In the summertime,
summer vacation,
I wouldn't take it.
And within a day that's of kicking
herself out of your system,
man,
your appetite comes back.
And in ninth or 10th grade I started
weightlifting and I started like throwing
the pills out because it's a,
it's an APP,
it's speed.
And so it suppresses your appetite.
And so I'm going through puberty,
my hormones are raging and I stopped
using the tablet and all of a sudden I'm
that guy at lunch,
we're like the,
the,
the line of milk on the outer edge
of the tray because I'm eating like,
you know,
tons of food and the locust until I'm
going to the gym and I'm just getting
really,
my frustration is now being informed
by a physicality that I'm getting by
lifting weights.
So all of a sudden I'm putting muscle
on and I'm angry at the world and I'm a
spazz.
And so by 12th grade I was kind of a
maniac and then I got into punk rock and
you know,
just got,
got into that slug fest and just kind of
went into the world just kind of wildly
swinging away.
Who the eff,
why did they put you on
Ritalin at such a young age?
Because it's what they were
doing in America with a lot
of young people who talk
too much or you know,
had that social skills well on energy
and attention deficit and it couldn't
concentrate.
And I got thrown out of the
DC public school system,
uh,
for being,
you know,
he's yelling,
he's doing this and I actually read a
couple of teachers reports about me years
later and I said,
I had no memory.
I said,
I did all that.
My mom went,
yeah,
that's why they kicked you out.
They kicked you out of school.
Wow.
Yeah.
And uh,
I got kicked out of a few
schools until they put me in a,
in a prep school where
the advertising is like,
oh,
your kid has problems
with studying will cool.
I'm out.
And I,
the first few days of school,
some kids spoke at a class and I watched
this one teacher picked this one kid up
and just kind of toss him into a
blackboard and went right in his class.
You shut up.
And so I,
I didn't want to get,
you know,
a thrashing by a teacher.
So I was always really careful.
But having that difficulty sitting down
and I was fine with topics I liked.
I didn't,
you know,
I didn't groove on math or any of that,
but at lunchtime I'd go to the
library and start memorizing the Latin
nomenclature of every
North American snake.
I had to learn them all and
by like 10th grade I had,
and I have most of it's still in my head,
but I'm always very confused
at these medical distinctions,
whether it's Adhd or hyperactive or add,
whatever the fuck it is like is,
is that real or do people just do,
some people just have a
different composition,
a different passion inside of them and
they resist doing things they don't want
to do and they don't want to be a part
of any structured school curriculum.
I think all of it,
but it,
yeah.
And is that a disease or is that,
or do you just have more fucking and
looking right now that don't have any
pills,
you're not on anything and yet
you have all his passion for life.
You have all this.
Isn't that the same shit that
you had when you were six?
Yeah,
it was undisciplined and unfocused type.
But that does that.
It's not a disease.
Right?
I Dunno.
I mean,
I wouldn't call it a disease,
I think as this wiring.
Right.
But why the fuck is it named?
Why is it Adh so they can,
why is it so they can sell you a pill?
I know,
but isn't that crazy?
Well,
you look back at your own life,
the fact that you were on that shit for,
I mean,
what,
how many years?
Eight years.
Nine years really screws with you.
Cause you can feel it when you take the,
the pill,
you can,
you're basically,
you're a propeller that spins so fast
when it looks like they're like go spokes
of a wheel.
Like the wheels still,
it's actually going really fast.
That's how it felt like on the
outside I'm like this pale skinny,
like eh,
but inside,
I'm like the last few minutes of,
uh,
Dave in 2001 where he's coming
in spacetime in genuine,
everything is flying by.
That was like 10th grade for me.
I just kind of held onto my desk
and fairly flew through classes,
like not being able to retain much because
I was just speeding my brains out and
then the pill would wear off around
dinner and all of a sudden you're like
eating two meals and the next morning
you take the pill and you don't eat again
for hours.
That is fucking crazy.
It was nuts and scares the shit out of
me too because my parents didn't put me
on anything like that,
but I know I would've,
I know I would've been diagnosed.
I know I would have been put on
something if I had the wrong parents.
Yeah,
they put me on,
my mom put me on this stuff
probably because my doctor said,
you know,
hey iris,
this helps a lot of kids.
But I was in these classes and I'll
never forget one day I'm going through my
mom's books.
There's just this big Honkin hardcover
book and I opened it up and I saw these
like a contact sheet of me.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
That's that place.
And then I saw the camera angle and I
realized there were these mirrors on the
wall,
their observation rooms.
I'll never forget one day I'm looking at
that mirror and a door opened from the
side and my mom walked out and they would,
we were being observed and the camera
angle was from that observation room.
And there's me playing
with blocks and stuff.
I'm like,
I remember that sweater.
Oh Man,
I'm like four.
And that was part of that research group.
Wow.
And maybe,
cause my mom was a government employee,
I dunno,
but I was,
uh,
I went to a place called it like for
two years called the national research
center.
I got thrown out of there wow.
For wounding a kid,
which due to him through a bunch
of powdered cement in his face.
Okay.